since twilight came out over a decade
ago
its stars have gone on to enjoy success
in both mainstream and
indie film roles while others have
transitioned into tv
or moved away from hollywood entirely
here's what the cast has been up to
in the years since twilight concluded
she'd made movies before signing on for
the saga
but kristen stewart became an
international superstar overnight
by starring as bella in the twilight
franchise
she quickly landed other leading roles
including starring in the joan jett
biopic the runaways once she wrapped her
time in the twilight series
she became a spokesperson for fashion
houses such as chanel
and balenciaga she also had a small role
in 2012's into the wild
eventually stewart transitioned from
starring in blockbusters to working on
smaller indie films
in 2014 she starred in camp x-ray
receiving critical acclaim for her
portrayal of a guard stationed at
guantanamo bay
she also co-starred with chloe 70 in
2018's lizzie portraying lizzie borden's
lover and accomplice to the infamous
killings of borden's father
and stepmother stewart has also tried
her hand behind
the camera writing and directing a short
film come swim
in 2017. after working consistently as
an
indie darling for several years stewart
reemerged as a blockbuster force once
again with starring roles
in 2019's charlie's angels and 2020s
underwater
more recently she starred in hulu's
happiest season
playing abby a woman who is invited to
her girlfriend's home
for the holidays as one of the first
major holiday
films to center around a same-sex couple
happiest season
became a cultural touch point for
discussions about lgbtq stories in film
all while stoking passionate debate
among viewers over who stuart's
character should have ended up with
like his co-star kristen stewart robert
pattinson
also found success soon after starring
in the twilight franchise
landing major roles in remember me and
water for elephants
both films received mixed reviews but
critics praised pattinson's clear
attempt to move away from teen idol
roles
something that would become a recurring
theme as he continued to build his
post-twilight career
he also became the face of fashion house
dior alms fragrance and menswear lines
throughout the 2010s pattinson appeared
in different roles in various
genres outside of the twilight films
including the safety brothers his
thriller good time
he went on to land several prominent
roles in 2019
including historical dramas the king and
waiting for the barbarians
2020 also proved to be a productive time
for pattinson who starred in christopher
nolan's highly anticipated thriller
tenet
the first major hollywood release that
opened in theaters
after initial shutdowns due to the kobit
19 pandemic
in what might be his most anticipated
role to date
pattinson landed the lead in the batman
donning the cowl
set aside when ben affleck vacated the
role following justice league
anna kendrick had a small supporting
role in twilight as jessica stanley
a high school student who happily brings
bella into the fold when she moves to
forks washington the year after she
appeared in twilight
she had her own moment in the spotlight
when she starred in 2009's
up in the air alongside george clooney a
role for which
she was nominated for an academy award a
golden globe
and screen actors guild award she went
on to play a supporting role in edgar
wright's
scott pilgrim versus the world as scott
pilgrim's
sister stacy who is this mystery child
you gave
her name's knives chao she's chinese a
17 year old chinese
school girl in 2012 kendrick became an
even more recognizable household name
when she starred in pitch perfect she
later reprised her role as becca
mitchell
an ambitious college student who strives
to be a music producer
in both pitch perfect sequels she
appeared in several musical roles in
films like the last five years
and into the woods drawing from her
experience on broadway
prior to her twilight days in 2016
she had her first major voice acting
role when she portrayed
princess poppy in trolls she has most
recently appeared in the black comedy a
simple favor
and the holiday film noel in the
twilight saga
kellen lutz played emmett cullen edwards
buff
and lovable adopted brother after this
he worked on a few horror films
such as after dusk they come and the
2010 remake of a nightmare on
elm street he also starred in a sports
romance film
a warrior's heart alongside his twilight
co-star ashley green
shortly after his twilight role wrapped
let's portrayed
several iconic characters in various
films such as 2013's tarzan
and 2014's the legend of hercules he
also had a small part in the ensemble
cast of the expendables 3
alongside sylvester stallone mel gibson
and harrison ford
in recent years lutz has found success
working in network tv
he appeared in the cbs series fbi as
fbi special agent kenny crosby and later
starred in the show's
spin-off series fbi most wanted outside
of acting
lutz has done lots of charity work he
was named one of gq's gentleman of the
year in 2013
for his work with charity saving
innocence which protects victims
of child sex trafficking billy burke had
a small supporting role in twilight
as bella swan's protective father and
forked his police chief
shortly after his appearance in the
first twilight film he worked on several
thrillers
such as 2008's untraceable and 2011's
drive angry
he also worked with twilight director
catherine hardwick in 2011's red riding
hood
playing the father of the film's titular
character on television
burke played philip stroh a recurring
antagonist on tnt's the closer he
reprised this role in spin-off series
major crimes
until his character's death in the
series finale in 2012
burke also starred in revolution a
sci-fi series that ran for two seasons
on nbc
the show received generally positive
reviews and had a passionate fan base
in 2020 burke appeared in lone star
as well as the quibby series most
dangerous game he's also set to appear
in the netflix dramedy series
made like his co-stars kristen stewart
and robert pattinson
taylor lautner was thrust into the
spotlight immediately following his
appearance in the first
twilight film lautner played bella's
longtime friend
and love interest jacob black who also
happens to be
a werewolf in 2010 he was a member of
the ensemble cast of rom-com
valentine's day in the film lautner's
character willie
is the love interest of taylor swift's
character felicia
in 2011 lautner took the lead role in
abduction
but the film was panned with many
critics specifically criticizing
lautner's performance
lautner's other foray into being an
action league
tracers similarly received negative
reviews
despite lautner's challenges in
hollywood he's found success
in recent years on tv he had a main role
on bbc's comedy series kaku
for three seasons lautner also had a
main role
in ryan murphy's black comedy series
scream queens
in the years immediately following
jackson rathbone's appearance
in the first twilight film as jasper
hale he appeared in horror films such as
dread
and hurt in 2010 he also starred in m
night shyamalan's
live action version the last airbender
which was based on the beloved
nickelodeon animated series the film
faced widespread backlash for casting
white actors to portray characters who
many viewers believed were of
east asian or inuit descent in 2019
he starred in the wall of mexico as dawn
a handyman for a mexican-american family
the film was met with a mostly positive
response from critics who also praised
rathbone's performance
apart from acting rathbone also started
a funk
rock band called 100 monkeys during the
years the band was active
the multi-talented rathbone played
guitar bass
and drums in 2012 he left the band when
his then-girlfriend sheila half sadie
gave
birth to their first child he and taf
sadie later got married in 2013
and have since had two more children
ashley greene was a fan favorite in the
twilight saga for her bubbly and
charismatic portrayal of alice kellen
shortly after she starred in skateland
portraying a teen who works at a texas
roller rink
in 2011 she appeared alongside fellow
twilight co-star kellen lutz in a
warrior's heart
and was part of an all-star ensemble
cast in butter
in 2012 she starred in the rom-com lol
as miley cyrus's high school nemesis
while also appearing in various horror
and thriller films
throughout the early 2010s including the
apparition
christie burying the x urge and
accident man on television she had a
main role on the police procedural
rogue more recently green starred in
hallmark channels
a little christmas charm aside from her
on-screen work
she's also done voice acting work for
the batman arkham knight video game
peter facinelli played carlisle cullen
the patriarch in the cullen family in
the twilight film franchise
vaginelli's most prominent and
recognizable role outside of twilight
was on the medical series nurse jackie
where he played
dr fitch cooper a charismatic but naive
emergency room doctor who flirts with
the show's protagonist
jackie he also had a recurring role on
glee as a broadway director running a
revival
of funny girl in 2015 he starred in
nbc's american odyssey
a military thriller series most recently
he starred in escaping the nexium cult
a 2019 lifetime movie that was inspired
by the real
story of the nexium sex cult led by
keith reinier and smallville actress
alison mack
fachinelli has worked both on set and
behind the scenes
for example in 2011 he wrote produced
and starred in a romantic dramedy lucy's
in which she played a free-spirited new
york pickpocket
before appearing in the twilight films
nikki reed made her first appearance on
the big screen in katherine hardwick's
film
13 for which she co-wrote the script
with hardwick when she was just a
teenager
shortly after her appearance in twilight
she appeared in crime thriller catch 44
as well as numerous straight to dvd
films
in reed's personal life she's remained
very close friends with
several of her twilight co-stars she was
even named the godmother of jackson
rathbone's
first child monroe jackson rathbone the
sixth
she's also started her own family with
the vampire diaries ian somerhalder
giving birth to their first child in
2017.
outside of hollywood reed started a
sustainable jewelry brand called bayou
with love the company creates its
jewelry by recycling gold
including golds recovered from old
electronics
once you start thinking in this way you
start
questioning all the decisions you make
reed designs the brand's collections of
wedding rings and
more casual everyday jewelry herself
elizabeth reiser played esme
the cullen matriarch in the twilight
series before this
she was perhaps best known for her
recurring role on grey's anatomy as
eva a patient who suffers from severe
memory loss and
falls in love with dr alex karev since
her time on twilight
reeser has had recurring and guest
starring roles on several tv shows
she also starred in her own cbs series
the x list
as bella bloom a woman who must revisit
her past relationships to find her
soulmate
the show was cancelled after four
episodes due to poor ratings
aside from her work on the twilight
films reese's films have included young
adult
and liberal arts most recently she
starred in netflix's highly acclaimed
the haunting of hill house
a horror series centered on a haunted
mansion and the family that lives in it
reeser played surely the eldest daughter
who owns a mortuary
gill birmingham had one of the smaller
roles on twilight as billy black
jacob black's father and charlie swan's
best friend
billy was a minor part in the first
twilight film but became a more
significant character once jacob
underwent his first werewolf
transformation in new moon after
birmingham concluded his role in the
twilight saga
he appeared in several films including
2013's the lone ranger
and 2016's hell or high water in 2017
he starred alongside jeremy renner in
wind river
which received positive reviews and
reignited conversations
surrounding indigenous representation in
film
on the small screen birmingham has had
several guest and recurring appearances
across
various shows and networks he was a
recurring actor on netflix's hit series
house of cards
as daniel lanigan a us congressman and
casino owner he also appeared on
netflix's comedy series
unbreakable kimmy schmidt as the father
of jane krakowski's character
since 2018 he starred in paramount drama
yellowstone which follows the conflicts
between a ranch family
land developers and native americans who
live on a nearby reservation
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss
a single one
you